MATT FROST: Welcome to the first
session on WebM and the
New VP9 Open Video Codec.
We figured that there's no way
to really add a little
excitement to a presentation
than to change it at the last
minute, and so what we've spent
this morning doing is
encoding some VP9 video and
H.264 video and putting
together a side by side
demonstration just to give you
a taste of what we're
working on.
So what you're going
to see is a video.
The video is going to be the
same on either side.
It's going to be VP9, the
new codec on the left,
H.264 on the right.
And H.264, we used the X264 open
video encoder, which is
commonly regarded as the
best encoder out there.
We used the highest
possible settings.
So we've done everything we
can to favor H.264 here.
All of this is at the same
data rate, so both of the
videos are going to be at
the same data rate.
And the bit rate varies.
In some cases, we're
using 500K.
In other cases, we've dropped
the bit rate down to bit rates
that are actually banned by
certain UN conventions for the
compression of HD video.
And so with that, I think that's
everything, Ronald?
RONALD BULTJE: Yes.
So like Matt said, what you're
looking at here is shots that
we just took this morning.
We've encoded those in just a
couple of hours and basically,
what you're looking at here,
on the left, VP9 and on the
right, H.264, is what an amazing
job we can actually do
at video compression if we're
using the very latest
technologies.
MATT FROST: So you can see the
blockiness on the right.
On some of this, it's a lot more
evident than others, and
especially evident, if you want
afterwards to come up and
take a look at this running
on the screen,
we can freeze frames.
But you see there on the right
especially, all this
blockiness and how much
it clears up as it
moves into VP9 territory.
RONALD BULTJE: And a point here
really is that for high
definition video, H.264 can do
a reasonable job, but we can
do a lot better than that.
And so having said that, let's
actually get started on the
presentation.
MATT FROST: So the way that
we're going to handle this
presentation is I'm going to do
a quick introduction on why
we care about open video,
both why does Google--
which has historically been
involved with developing
applications around video--
has gotten down deeply into
actually helping work on these
next generation compression
technologies.
After we talk about that and
why, in general, improving
video compression is good for
everybody, I'm going to turn
it over to Ronald for really the
meat of this presentation,
which will be to show you some
more demonstrations, to talk a
little bit about how we measure
video quality, talk
about some of the techniques
that we're exploiting to
really make this dramatic
improvement in compression.
And then finally, after you've
seen this, and I hope that
you've started to get a little
excited about what this
technology can do for you, we'll
go and talk about the
last stages, how we're going
to wrap up this project and
how we're going to get these
tools into your hands as
quickly as possible.
So to start off with, just
taking a quick look at how
Google got into video.
Video at Google started in the
same way that so many big
projects at Google start,
as an experiment.
And we launched these efforts
with just a single full time
engineer and a number of
engineers working 20% of their
time on video, really focusing
on video-related data.
And then over the last 10 years,
obviously, video at
Google has exploded, not only
with YouTube but with Google
Talk, Hangouts, lots of
applications where you
wouldn't necessarily think of
video as playing a core role,
like Chromoting, which is Chrome
Remote Desktopping.
But if you look at the really
motivating factors for getting
into video compression, there
are a couple that
are really of note.
One, of course, is the
acquisition of YouTube.
And with the acquisition of
YouTube, we all of a sudden
started to focus very heavily
on both improving the
experience for users, improving
video quality, but
also about the costs associated
with all aspects of
running a service
like YouTube.
There are costs associated
with ingest, transcode of
video formats, storage of
multiple different formats,
and then distribution of the
video, both to caches and to
the edge, and ultimately
to users.
The second was the move from
HTML4 to HTML5, which came at
the same time, pretty much,
as our launch of Chrome.
And of course, in HTML4,
although to the user, it
appeared that video could be
supported in a browser, in
fact, video was supported
through runtimes and plug-ins.
With HTML5, video becomes a
native part of the browser.
And so with the move towards
HTML5, we see it filtering
through the addition of the
video tag in Chrome and the
launch of HTML5 video
for YouTube.
So these are the two factors--
the focus on quality and
reducing cost with YouTube,
the need to build a high quality
codec into Chrome and
other browsers for
the video tag--
that sparked the acquisition in
2010 of On2 Technologies,
the company that I came from and
many members of the WebM
team came from, and the launch
of the WebM project.
The WebM project is an effort
to develop a high quality,
open alternative
for web video.
We're very focused on web
video, not on video for
Blu-ray discs, not on video
for cable television, but
about solving the problems that
we find in web video.
In addition, we're very focused
on having an open
standard because we believe that
the web has evolved as
quickly is it has because it is
based on open technologies.
And clearly, multimedia
communication has become such
a core part of how we
communicate on the web that we
need open technologies that are
rapidly evolving to allow
us to keep pace and to make sure
that we can develop the
next generation of killer
video applications.
We wanted something
simple as well.
So we used the VP8 Open Codec,
the Vorbis Open Audio Codec,
which was a long existing open
audio codec, and then them the
Matroska File Wrapper.
With the launch of VP9 in a
matter of months, we're going
to be adding the VP9 Video Codec
as well as the brand new
Opus Audio Codec, which is
another open audio codec, very
performant and high quality.
So since our launch, obviously,
web video has
continued to grow.
And if we just look at what we
know very well, which is
YouTube, YouTube has grown to
be a global scale video
platform capable of serving
video across the globe to
these myriad connected
video enabled devices
that we're all using.
It supports a billion monthly
users, and those users are
looking at video four billion
times a day for a total of six
billion plus hours of video
viewed monthly.
Just to think about that number,
that is an hour of
video for every person on the
planet consumed on YouTube.
And on the creation
side, we're seeing
exactly the same trends.
72 hours of video is uploaded
per minute, and that video is
increasingly becoming
HD video.
So if you look at the graph
on the right, blue is 360p
standard definition video, which
is slowly declining, but
quickly being matched by
uploads of HD video.
And the key here of great
importance is that HD video is
obviously more complex.
There's more data for a given
HD video than there is for--
unless, of course, you're
encoding it in VP9--
than there is for a standard
resolution video.
In addition, I think we can all
agree that the better the
video is, the higher the
resolution, the more
watchable it is.
And then finally, the other
trend that's driving both
creation and consumption is the
increase in mobile devices
and the move towards
4G networks.
So even this morning, there was
an article when I woke up
and was checking my email saying
that YouTube video
accounts for 25% of
all downstream
web traffic in Europe.
And I think BitTorrent
accounted for 13%.
So there alone, between just two
web video services, we're
looking at close to 40% of all
web data in Europe being video
related data.
And that accords with what we
see from the latest Cisco
forecasts, for instance, which
is that consumer web video is
going to be close to 90% of all
consumer data on the web
within the next three years.
So it's remarkably encouraging
to see the growth in video,
but it also represents
a real challenge.
Of course, the good news is that
we have a technology that
is up to this challenge,
and that is VP9.
With next generation video
codecs, with the codecs as
good as VP9, we can effectively
significantly
increase the size of the
internet and we can
significantly increase the
speed of the internet.
So obviously, if you're
taking VP9--
which, as Ronald will say,
halves the bit rate you need
for the very best H.264
to deliver a
given quality video--
you're going to be able to
speed the downloaded of a
download and play a video,
you're going to be able to
speed, obviously, the buffering
of these videos.
So we have the tools to
effectively dramatically
increase the size
of the internet.
But of course in doing that,
in improving the video
experience, in improving the
ability to upload video
quickly, we're going to just
create the conditions for even
more consumption of video.
And so it's not going to be
enough for us to rest on our
laurels with VP9.
We're going to have to turn to
VP9 and keep on doing it, keep
on pushing the boundaries of
what we're capable of with
video compression.
So with that, I'm going to turn
it over to Ronald to show
you some really remarkable
demonstrations of this new
technology.
RONALD BULTJE: Thank you.
So to get started, I just
briefly want to say some words
about video quality.
So how do we measure quality?
Well, the most typical way to
measure quality is to just
look at it, because at the end
of the day, the only thing
that we care about is that the
video that you're looking at
looks great to your eyes.
But that's, of course, not all
there is to it because as
we're developing a new video
codec, we cannot spend our
whole day just watching YouTube
videos over and over
and over again.
That would be fun, though.
So in addition to visually
analyzing and inspecting
video, we're also
using metrics.
The most popular metric in the
field for measuring video
quality is called PSNR.
It stands for Peak Square
Noise Ratio.
And the graph that you're
looking at here on the left is
a typical representation of PSNR
on the vertical axis and
video bit rate on the horizontal
axis to give you
some sort of a feeling of
how those two relate.
So the obvious thing to note
here is that as you increase
the bit rate, the video quality,
as measured by this
metric, increases.
So at the end of the day what
that means is that it doesn't
really matter what code you
use, as long as you've
infinite bandwidth, you can
accomplish any quality.
However, our goal is to make
it easier and faster and
simpler to stream video.
So how does PSNR actually
compare to visual quality?
So for that, there's
a sample clip.
So what you're looking here is
a very high penalty shot of
the New York skyline.
I believe that this is the
Empire State Building.
And this clip has a lot of
detailed textures all across.
So what we've done here is
that we've encoded it at
various bit rates, and then
every couple of seconds, we're
dropping the bit rate and the
metric quality of the video
will slowly decrease.
So this is 45 dB, and what
you're seeing slowly at 30 dB
is that some of the detail, or
actually a lot of the detail,
in the backgrounds of the
buildings just completely
disappears.
And that was the case at
35 dB already also.
As you go to 25 dB, you can
see-- we can go really low in
quality, but you do not
want to watch this.
Here's a different scene.
Same thing, we start with
the original 45 dB.
40 dB looks pretty good.
35 dB starts having a lot of
artifacts, and then 30 and 25
are essentially unwatchable.
So what does that mean
for video quality?
Well, the typical target quality
for high definition
video on the internet
lies rounds 40 dB.
You were just looking at the
video, and a 40 dB looked
really quite good.
So if you go to YouTube and
you try to stream a 720p
video, that's actually about the
quality that you will get.
In terms of bit rate, what you
should expect to get is a
couple of megabits a second.
For this particular clip, that's
one to two megabits a
second, but that's very source
material dependent.
So what we've done, then, is we
have taken, I think, about
1,000 YouTube CCL licensed
uploads, just randomly
selected from whatever users
give us, and we've then taken
out particular material that
we're not really interested
in, such as stills or video
clips that contain garbage
video content.
And then we were left with, I
think, about 700 CCL licensed
YouTube uploads, and we've
encoded those at various bit
rates-- so at various
quality settings--
with our VP9 Video Codec or
with H.264 using the X264
encoder at the very best
settings that we are aware of.
Then for each of these clips,
we've taken the left half of
the resulting compressed file
and the right half of the 264
one and we've stitched those
back together, and then you
essentially get what you're
looking at here.
So left here is VP9, right is
264, and those are at about
the same bit rate.
You will see graphs here on the
left and on the right, and
those are actually the effective
bit rate for this
particular video clip.
And as you can see, it starts
being about equal.
Now, you saw it just jumping up,
and that's because we're
gradually increasing the bit
rate to allow the 264 encoder
to catch up in quality.
And as you can see, it slowly,
slowly starts looking a little
bit better.
And at this point, I would say
that it looks about equal on
the left and on the right.
But if you look at the bit rate
graphs, you can basically
see that we're spending about
two and a half times the bit
rate on a 264 file versus
the VP9 file.
So those are the compression
savings that you can get if
you do same quality encodings
but you use
VP9 instead of 264.
So what you're looking at here
is a comparative graph for the
clip that you were
just looking at.
The blue line is the 264 encoded
version and the red
line is the VP9 encoded
version.
And as I said in the beginning,
vertical axis is
PSNR as a metric of
quality, and the
horizontal axis is bit rate.
So the way that you compare
these is that you can pick any
point from the red line--
or from the blue line,
for that matter--
and then you can
do two things.
Either you can draw a vertical
line and find the matching
point on a blue line that
matches the points on the red
line that you're looking for
and look at what the
difference in quality is.
But what we usually do is we
do it the other way around.
So we're drawing a horizontal
line for the point on the red
graph, and we're finding the
point that matches the
horizontal line on the blue.
And what you're looking at here
is that for the point
that we were just looking at,
that is, a quality metric
point of about 37.1 dB, the VP9
version takes an average
of 328 kilobits a second to
reach that quality, and for
H.264, you need to go up to
essentially 800 kilobits a
second to get exactly
the same quality.
So what that means is, again,
the metrics tell us you can
get a two and a half times lower
bit rate and effectively
get the same quality by using
VP9 instead of 264.
If you look to the higher end
of the graph, you will see
that the differences in quality
for the same bit rates
might go slightly down, but
that's basically just because
at the higher end, there's
a diminishing
returns for bit rate.
So if you look at the high ends
of both of those graphs
and you do the horizontal line
comparison, so what is the
different bit rate that
accomplishes the same quality?
You will see that it about
comes down to 2x over the
whole graph.
So let's look at the difference
video because I
could just be cheating you with
this one video and we
could have optimized our codec
for this one video.
So what you're looking at here
is, again, the same thing, VP9
on the left, 264 on the right,
live bit rate graphs and we
start at the same bit rate.
Then as we do that, we're slowly
increasing the bit rate
for the 264 portion video so
that it can actually catch up
in quality.
And what you're looking at is
that on the right, the floor
is pulsing a lot.
You can actually see, if you
focus on the pants of little
boy here or on the plastic box,
that it's very noisy.
But eventually, it catches
up in quality.
Guess what happened
to the bit rate?
It's almost 3x for this
particular video.
So here is the [INAUDIBLE] graph
for the material that we
were just looking at.
The red line is VP9, the
blue line is H.264.
And if we do the same quality
different bit rate comparison
at the point that we were just
looking at, which is about
38.6 dB, for VP9, you arrive
at about 200 kilobits a
second, and for H.264, you need
to interpolate between
two points because we don't have
an exact match, and it
ends up being around 550
kilobits a second.
So almost 3x more bit rates to
accomplish the same quality,
just because you can use
VP9 to save this.
So we've done this over
many, many clips.
I told you we had about 700
clips that we tested this on
at various bit rates and various
quality settings, and
overall, you can save 50%
bandwidth by encoding your
videos in VP9 instead of H.264
at the very best settings that
we are aware of.
So how did we do this?
So let's look a little bit at
the techniques that we're
using to actually get to this
kind of compression
efficiency.
So a typical video sequence
consists of a series of video
frames, and then each of
these video frames
consist of square blocks.
So for current generation video
codecs, like H.264,
these blocks have a size of
a maximum 16 by 16 pixels.
We've blown this up a lot.
We have currently gone up to
64 by 64 pixels for each
block, and then at that
point, we introduce a
partitioning step.
And in this partitioning step,
we allow you to do a vertical
or horizontal partitioning,
a four-way split, or no
partitioning at all, resulting
in different size sub-blocks.
If you do a four-way split and
you have four 32 by 32 blocks,
then for each of these blocks,
you go through the same
process again of horizontal,
vertical split, four-way
split, or no split at all.
If you do the four-way split,
you get down to 16 by 16
pixels, do the same thing
again to get to eight by
eight, and eventually
four by four pixels.
So what this partitioning step
allows you to do is to break
up the video in such a way that
it's optimized for your
particular content.
Stuff that has a very stable
motion field can use very
large blocks, whereas video
content where things are
moving all across all the time,
you can go to very small
video blocks.
So what do we you
do after that?
So after this partitioning
step, we're usually doing
motion vector coding, and
basically what that does is
that you pick a reference frame,
and you pick a motion
vector, and then the block of
that particular size that you
selected in your partitioning
step will be coded using a
motion vector pointing in one
of the previously coded
reference frames.
These reference frames in VP8
were usually frames that had
previously been encoded, and
were therefore temporarily
before the current frame.
What we've added in VP9 is that
we have multi-level alt
reference frames, and what
that allows you to do is
encode the video sequence in any
frame order, and then you
can use any future frame as a
reference frame for a frame
that you encode in order, decide
to encode after that.
So for this series
of frames in the
left, this is six frames.
I could, for example, choose the
first thing encode frame
one, then frame six, and then
frame three using both a
future as well as a
past reference.
And then, now that I have
encoded three, I can encode
one and two really efficiently
because they have a very
proximate future and
past reference.
After I've encoded two and
three, I go to five, which has
four and six as close
neighbors.
And so that allows for very
temporally close reference
frames to be used as a predictor
of contents in the
current block.
So once you have a motion
vector, you can use subpixel
filtering, and subpixel
filtering allows you to
basically pick a point in
between two full pixels and
this point in between is then
interpolated using a subpixel
interpolation filter.
In VP8, we had only a single
subpixel interpolation filter.
Most codecs use just a single
We've actually added three in
VP9, and those are optimized
for different types
of material.
We have a sharp subpixel
interpolation filter, which is
really great for material where
there's a very sharp
edge somewhere in the middle.
For example, that city clip that
we were looking at in the
beginning, if you're thinking of
a block that happens to be
somewhere on the border
between the sky and a
building, we consider that a
sharp edge, and so using an
optimized filter for sharp edges
actually maintains a lot
of that detail.
On the other hand, sometimes
there's very sharp edges but
those are not consistent across
video frames across
different temporal points in
the sequence that you're
looking at.
And that point, this will cause
a very high frequency
residual artifact, and
so for those, we've
added a low pass filter.
And what the low pass filter
does is that it basically
removes sharp edges, and it does
exactly the opposite as a
sharp filter.
Lastly, we have a regular
filter, which is similar to
the one that VP8 had.
After this prediction step,
you have predicted block
contents and you have the
actual block that you're
trying to get as close as
possible to, and then the
difference between these two
is the residual signal that
you're going to encode.
So in current generation video
codecs, we usually use four by
four or eight by eight cosine
based transforms called DCTs
to encode this residual
signal.
What we've added in VP9 is much
higher resolution DCT
transforms all the way up to
32 by 32 pixels, and in
addition to using the DCT, we've
also added an asymmetric
sine based transform
called ADST.
And the sine based transform is
optimized for a signal that
has a near zero value at the
edge of the predicted region,
whereas the cosine is optimized
for a residual
signal that has a zero signal
in the middle of
the predicted signal.
So those are optimized for
different conditions, and
together, they give good gains
when used properly.
Basically, the take home message
from all of this is
that we've added big resolution
increments to our
video codecs, and what that
leads to is a codec that is
highly, highly optimized for
high definition video coding.
But at the same time, because
it is very configurable, it
still performs really well at
low resolution content, for
example, SIF-based 320
by 240 video as well.
So I'll hand it back to Matt
now, who will take over.
MATT FROST: Thanks, Ronald.
So I just want to give you a
quick recap of what we've
discussed and sort of the
highlights of this technology,
and then to tell you about the
last steps that we're going
through to get VP9
in your hands.
As Ronald said, we're talking
about technology here that is
50% better than literally
everything that everybody else
out there is using.
And actually, we made a point to
say we were using the very
best encoder out there at the
very best settings, settings
which I really think you're not
seeing very often in the
real world because they're very
difficult to use in a
real world encoding
environment.
So I hope that there are a
number of people in this
audience now who are out there,
either with existing
products with video or products
to which you're
looking to add video, or just
you're thinking about how you
can use these tools to launch a
new product and to come out
with a start-up.
This technology has not been
used by anyone right now.
YouTube is testing it and we'll
talk about that in a
little bit, but if you adopt
VP9, as you can very quickly,
you will have a tremendous
advantage over anybody out
there with their current
offering based
on 264 or even VP8.
It's currently available in
Chrome, and the libvpx library
on the WebM project is out there
for you to download,
compile, and test.
It's open source.
You will have access
to source code.
The terms of the open source
license are incredibly liberal
so that you can take the code,
improve it, optimize it,
modify it, integrate it with
your proprietary technology,
and you're not going to have to
give back a line of code to
the project.
You're not going to have to
be concerned that you will
inadvertently open source your
own proprietary code.
And then finally, it's
royalty free.
And obviously, this is something
that was of great
importance to us as we sought
to open source a video
technology for use in HTML5
and the video tag.
We believe that the best is
still to come in terms of
video products on the web, and
that in order to make sure
that people are free to innovate
and that start-ups
are free to launch great new
video products, we have to
make sure that they're not
writing $5 or $6 million
checks a year to standards
bodies.
We're working very hard on
putting this technology into
your hands as soon
as possible.
We did a semi freeze of the bit
stream just a couple of
weeks ago, and at that time,
we said that we were taking
comments on the bit stream
for 45 more days.
Specifically, we're looking for
comments from a lot of our
hardware partners to some of the
software techniques that
we're using just to make sure
that we're not doing anything
that's incredibly difficult
to implement in hardware.
At the end of the 45 day period
on June 17, we're going
to be bit stream frozen, which
means that after June 17, any
VP9 encoder that you use is
going to be compliant with any
VP9 decoder, and that if you're
encoding content with
an encoder that's out after June
17, it's going to be able
to play back in a decoder after
the bit stream freeze.
Obviously, getting VP9
in Chrome is very
important to us.
The beta VP9 which you've
been seeing today
is already in Chrome.
If you download the latest
development version of Chrome
and enable the VP9 experiment,
you'll be able to play back
VP9 content immediately.
As soon as we've frozen the
bit stream as of June 17,
we're going to roll it into the
Dev Channel of Chrome as
well with this final version of
VP9, and then that's going
to work through the
beta channel and
through the stable channel.
And by the end of the summer,
we are going to have VP9 in
stable version of Chrome rolling
out to the hundreds of
millions of users.
I think [INAUDIBLE]
today said that there are
750 million users of
Chrome right now.
VP9 is going to be deployed
on a massive scale
by the end of summer.
In terms of final development
activities that we're going to
be working on, after the bit
stream is finalized in the
middle of June, we're going to
be focusing on optimizations
both for performance
and for platform.
So what that means is we'll be
working on making sure that
they encoder is optimized for
a production environment.
Obviously, something that's very
important to YouTube as
YouTube moves to supporting
VP9, that the decoder is
sufficiently fast to play
back on many of the PCs
that are out there.
We're also going to be working
on platform optimizations that
will be important to Android
developers, for instance, and
to people who want to support
VP9 on embedded devices.
These are ARM optimizations and
optimizations for other DSPs.
We have hardware designs
coming out.
For those of you who may work
with semiconductor companies
or are thinking about a
technology like this for use
in something like an action
camera, these are hardware
designs that get integrated
into a larger design for a
semiconductor and allow for
a fully accelerated VP9
experience.
Real time optimizations are
obviously incredibly important
for video conferencing, Skype
style applications, and also
for new applications that are
coming out like screencasting
and screen sharing.
By the end of Q3, we should have
real time optimizations
which allow for a very good
real time performance.
Those optimizations should
then allow VP9 to be
integrated into the WebRTC
project, which is a sister
project to the WebM project and
basically takes the entire
real time communication stack
and builds it into Chrome, and
more broadly into HTML5
capable browsers.
And so what this means is that
when VP9 is integrated into
WebRTC, you will have tools that
are open source, free for
implementation that used to,
even four years ago, require
license fees of hundreds of
thousands of dollars.
And you, with a few hundred
lines of JavaScript, should be
able to build the same sort of
rich video conferencing style
applications and screencasting
applications that you're
seeing with products
like Hangouts.
And finally, in the end of this
year moving into Q1 2014,
we're going to see,
again, hardware
designs for the encoder.
So just to give you an idea of
how usable these technologies
are, we have a VP9 demonstration
in YouTube.
If you download the Development
Version of Chrome
and flip the VP9 tag, you can
play back YouTube VP9 videos.
And one thing this should
drive home is this was a
project that was done over the
course of two weeks, that VP9
was built into YouTube.
Obviously, we have very
capable teams.
Obviously we have people on the
WebM team and people on
the YouTube team who know a
lot about these tools, but
this demonstration is VP9
in the YouTube operating
environment.
There's nothing canned here.
This is VP9 being encoded and
transmitted in the same way
that any other video is.
So this, I hope, again, will
give you guys pause to say,
god, we could do this as well.
We could come out very quickly
with a VP9 based service that
will be remarkably better
than anything that's
out there right now.
So I just want to leave you with
some thoughts about what
I hope that you're thinking
about coming away from this
presentation.
The WebM project is a true
community-based open source
project, and obviously, these
sorts of projects thrive on
contributions from
the community.
We are coming out of a period
where we've been very
intensively focused on algorithm
development.
Some of this work is certainly
very complicated stuff that
not every--
even incredibly seasoned--
software engineer can work on.
But we're moving into a point
where we're focusing on
application development, we're
focusing on optimization,
we're focusing on bug fixes and
patches, and that's the
sort of thing that people in
this room certainly can do.
So we encourage you to
contribute and we encourage
you to advocate for use
of these technologies.
We build open source
technologies, and yet simply
because we build them, that
doesn't mean that
people adopt them.
It takes work to get communities
to focus on
adopting these sorts of
open technologies.
So advocate within your project
in your company,
advocate within your company for
use of open technologies,
and advocate within the web
community as a whole.
We think that with VP9, we've
shown the power of a rapidly
developing, open technology, and
we hope that people are as
excited about this as we are and
that you go out and help
spread the word about
this technology.
But most important, we'd like
you to use the technology.
We're building this with a
purpose, and that is for
people to go out, take advantage
of these dramatic
steps forward that we've
made with VP9.
And so we hope you will go out,
that you'll be charged up
from this presentation, and
that you'll immediately
download the Development Version
of Chrome and start
playing around with this and
start seeing what you can do
with this tool that we've
been building for you.
So there are just a couple of
other things I'd like to say.
There are a couple of
other presentations
related to this project.
There's a presentation on
Demystifying Video Encoding,
Encoding for WebM VP8--
and this is certainly
relevant to VP9--
and then another on the
WebRTC project.
And again, if you're
considering a video
conferencing style application,
screensharing,
remote desktopping, this is
something that you should be
very interested in.
Sorry.
I shouldn't be using
PowerPoint.
So with that, we can open
it up to questions.
Can we switch to just the
Developers Screen, guys?
Do I do that?
AUDIENCE: Hey there.
VP8, VP9 on mobile, do you have
any plans releasing for
iOS and integrating with
my iOS applications--
Native, Objective
C, and stuff?
Do you have any plans
for that?
MATT FROST: He's asking
if VP8 is in iOS?
AUDIENCE: VP9 on iOS running
on top of Objective C.
RONALD BULTJE: So I think as
for Android, it's obvious
Android supports VP8 and
Android will eventually
support VP9 as well.
For iOS--
MATT FROST: When I was talking
about optimizations, platform
optimizations, talking about
VP9, that's the sort of work
we're focusing on, ARM
optimizations that should
apply across all of these ARM
SOCs that are prevalent in
Android devices and
iOS devices.
There aren't hardware
accelerators and iOS
platforms right now.
Obviously, that's something
we'd like to change, but
presently, if you're going to
try to support VP8 in iOS,
you're going to have to do
it through software.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RONALD BULTJE: Yep?
AUDIENCE: Bruce Lawson
from Opera.
I've been advocating WebM
for a couple of years.
One question.
I expect your answer is yes.
Is it your assumption that the
agreement that you came to
with MPEG LA about VP8 equally
applies to VP9?
MATT FROST: It does apply to
VP9 in a slightly different
way than it does with VP8.
The agreement with MPEG LA and
the 11 licensors with respect
to VP9 covers techniques that
are common with VP8.
So obviously, we've added back
some techniques we were using
in earlier versions, we've added
in some new techniques,
so there are some techniques
that aren't subject to the
license in VP9.
But yes, the core techniques
which are used in VP8 are
covered by the MPEG LA license,
and there will be a
VP9 license that will be
available for developers and
manufacturers to take
advantage of.
AUDIENCE: Super.
Follow up question.
About 18 months ago, the Chrome
team announced they
were going to drop H.264 being
bundled in the browser, and
that subsequently
didn't happen.
Can you comment further on
whether Chrome will drop H.264
and concentrate only on VP9?
MATT FROST: I can't
really comment
on plans going forward.
What I can say is that having
built H.264 in, it's very
difficult to remove
a technology.
I think when you look at the
difference between VP9 and
H.264, there's not
going to be any
competition between the two.
So I think with respect to VP9,
H.264 is slightly less
relevant because there
was nothing--
we didn't have our finger
on the scale for this
presentation.
And especially, we were hoping
to drive home with that
initial demonstration which we
put together over the last few
hours that we're not looking
for the best videos.
We're just out there
recording stuff.
So even if 264 remains
in Chrome--
which I think is probably
likely--
I don't think it's going to be
relevant for a next gen codec
because there's just such
a difference in quality.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
your answers.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
I have a question about
performance.
Besides the obvious difference
in royalty and licensing and
all that, can you comment on
VP9 versus HEVC, and do you
hope to achieve the same
performance or proof of
[INAUDIBLE]?
RONALD BULTJE: So the question
is in terms of quality, how do
VP9 and HEVC compare?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and bit rate
performance, yeah.
RONALD BULTJE: Right.
So testing HEVC is difficult.
I'll answer your question
in a second.
Testing HEVC is difficult
because there's currently no
either open source software or
commercial software available
that can actually encode
HEVC unless it's highly
developmental in nature or it
is the development model.
The problem with the alpha and
beta versions that are
currently on the market for
commercial products is that
we're not allowed to use them
in comparative settings like
we're doing.
Their license doesn't
allow us to do that.
Then the problem with the
reference model is it is a
really good encoder, it gives
good quality, but it is so
enormously slow.
It can do about 10 frames
an hour for a
high definition video.
That's just not something that
we can really use in YouTube.
But yes, we've done
those tests.
In terms of quality, they're
currently about equal.
There's some videos where HEVC,
the reference model, is
actually about 10%,
20% better.
There's also a couple of videos
where VP9 is about 10%,
20% better.
If you take the average over,
for example, all of those CCL
licensed YouTube clips that we
looked at, it's about a 1%
difference.
I think that 1% is in favor of
HEVC if you so wish, but 1% is
so small that really, we don't
think that plays a role.
What does that mean
going forward?
Well, we're really more
interested in commercial
software that will be out there
that actually encodes
HEVC at reasonable
speed settings.
And like I said, there's
currently nothing on the
market but we're really
interested in such products,
so once they are on the market
and we can use them, we
certainly will.
AUDIENCE: Follow-up question
about the performance.
Is this any reason to not expect
this to scale up to 4K
video or [INAUDIBLE]?
RONALD BULTJE: We think that
the current high definition
trend is mostly going towards
720p and 1080p.
So if you look at YouTube
uploads, there is basically no
4K material there, so it's
just really hard to find
testing materials, and that's
why we mostly use 720p and
1080p material.
MATT FROST: But certainly when
we designed the codec, we
designed it with 4K in mind.
There aren't any limitations
which are going to prevent it
from doing 4K.
RONALD BULTJE: Right.
You can use this all the way up
to 16K video if that's what
you were asking.
MATT FROST: Sir?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Have you been talking to the
WebRTC team, and do you know
when they're going to integrate
VP9 into their
current products?
MATT FROST: We talk with the
WebRTC team regularly.
As I said, we've got to finish
our real time enhancements in
order to actually have a codec
that works well in a real time
environment before we can expect
it to be integrated
into WebRTC.
But I think we're looking
at Q4 2013.
AUDIENCE: Great, thanks.
MATT FROST: We're
in 2013, right?
RONALD BULTJE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I just wanted to talk
about the rate of
change in video codecs.
I think maybe we can see like
VP8, VP9, we're talking about
an accelerating rate
of change.
And that's great, and I really
wanted to applaud the efforts
to getting this out in Chrome
Dev quickly, or
Chrome Stable quickly.
I just wanted to ask about
maybe some of your
relationships with other
software vendors that are
going to be relevant, like we're
talking Mozilla, IE, iOS
was, I think, previously
mentioned.
As this kind of rate of
innovation in codecs
increases, how are we going to
make sure that we can have as
few transcode targets
as possible?
My company is working
on a video product.
We don't want to have eight
different codecs.
And if we can imagine, let's
say, that Version 10 comes out
relatively soon, sometime
down the road.
How can we make sure that
devices stick with a
relatively small subset of
compatible decodings?
MATT FROST: I guess I'm
a little unsure
of what you're asking.
In terms of how we get support
on devices as quickly as
possible, or how we solve
the transcoding problem?
AUDIENCE: And just keeping the
number of transcoded formats
as small as possible.
If IE only supports
H.264, I have to
have an H.264 encoding.
So I was just wondering what
kind of relationships you guys
are working on to make sure
that as many devices and
platforms as possible can
support something like VP9.
MATT FROST: We're certainly
working very hard on that, and
as I said in the slide on next
steps showing the timeline,
our focus on having hardware
designs out there as quickly
as possible is an effort to try
to make sure that there's
hardware that supports VP9 more
rapidly than hardware has
ever been out to support
a new format.
We had a VP9 summit two weeks
ago, which was largely
attended by semiconductor
companies.
Actually, some other very
encouraging companies were
there with great interest in
these new technologies.
But we're working very hard with
our hardware partners and
with OEMs to make sure that this
is supported as quickly
as possible.
I think internally, what we're
looking at is probably relying
on VP8 to the extent that we
need hardware now and we don't
have it in VP9.
So I think what we've talked
about is always falling back
to an earlier version of an open
technology that has very
broad hardware support.
But we're trying to think very
creatively about things like
transcoding and things that we
can do to ensure backwards
compatibility or enhancement
layers.
So part of the focus of this
open development cycle and
process that we have is to
really try to think in very
new ways about how we support
new technologies while
maintaining the benefits of
hardware support or device
support for older
technologies.
AUDIENCE: Excellent.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So a key point in any
solution is going to be
performance.
Hardware acceleration really
solves that, and that was one
of the challenges with the
adoption of VP8 in timing
versus H.264, which has broad
spectrum hardware
acceleration.
I understand the timing, the
delays, and the efforts you
guys are doing to really
achieve that hardware
accelerated support for VP9.
But until then, what's the
software performance in
comparison to H.264, for
either both software,
software, or software,
hardware?
RONALD BULTJE: So we've only
done software, software
comparisons for that.
Let me start VP8 264.
Currently, VP8 decoding is about
twice as fast as 264
decoding using fully
optimized decoders.
VP9 is about twice as slow
currently as VP8, decoding,
and that basically means that
it's exactly at the same speed
as H.264 decoding.
That's not what we're targeting
as a final product.
We haven't finished fully
optimizing the decoder.
Eventually, what we hope to get
is about a 40% slowdown
from VP8 decoding, and that will
put it well ahead of the
fastest 264 decoders that are
out there in software.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I was just wanting to get some
background on the comparison
between H.264 and VP9.
For H.264, what were
you using--
CVR, BVR, and what QP values?
RONALD BULTJE: This is
two path encoding at
the target bit rate.
So it's preset very slow.
Since we're doing visual
comparison,
there is no tune set.
It's paths one or two, and then
just a target bit rate.
We tend to choose target bit
rates that are somewhere
between 100 and 1,000 kilobits
a second, and then we just
pick the same point for the VP9
one as well to start with.
AUDIENCE: So in both of the
comparisons, you were trying
to be very generic so you
weren't tuning the encoder in
any way to make it a better
quality at that bit rate.
You were just giving it two
paths to try to figure it out.
RONALD BULTJE: So you mean
visual quality, or--
AUDIENCE: Yes.
RONALD BULTJE: So we haven't
tuned either one of them for
any specific setting.
For 264, the default is that
it optimizes for visual
experience, and so that's why
we optimized it to 6414.
So it's not optimized for SSIM
or PSNR in the visual displace
that we did here.
VP9 encoding does not have any
such tunes, so we're not
setting any item, of course.
AUDIENCE: So you just used
the default settings of
[INAUDIBLE]?
RONALD BULTJE: We're using the
default settings, and we've
actually discussed this
extensively with the 264
developers.
They agree.
They support this kind of
testing methodology, and as
far as I'm aware, they
agree with it.
They fully expect the
kind of results that
we're getting here.
AUDIENCE: Right.
OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
One more question about
performance.
I think you mentioned a little
bit about the real time.
So do you think in the future,
you can manage to bring an
application like application
desktop into the web?
I mean like putting three,
four windows in the same
browser, high definition,
things like that?
RONALD BULTJE: In terms of
decoding or encoding?
AUDIENCE: Both.
RONALD BULTJE: So for
encoding, yes.
So there will be real time
settings for this codec
eventually.
For no codec will that get you
exactly the types of bit rate
quality ratios that you're
seeing here.
These are really using very slow
settings, and that is by
far not real time.
But if you set the VP9 codec
to real time settings, then
yes, eventually it will
encode in real time.
It will be able to do four full
desktops all at once, and
it will be able to decode
all of those also.
You'll probably need a multicore
machine for this,
obviously, but it will be
able to do it, yes.
AUDIENCE: And you're using
the graphics card and
other things like that.
You didn't mention about the
hardware, OpenGL or--
RONALD BULTJE: It's
future software.
There's no hardware involved.
AUDIENCE: No using the hardware,
the card hardware.
RONALD BULTJE: We're not using
GPU or anything like that at
this point.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I just want to know, how does
a VP9, now or later, compare
to VP8 and H.264 when we're
talking about single task CBR,
low bitrate, real
time encoding?
Little background is we are
part of the screen sharing
utility that currently uses
VP8, and we've been
successfully using it for a
year, but the biggest gripe
with VP8 is that it doesn't
respect bit rate, especially
on low bit rates, unless you
enable frame dropping, which
is unacceptable.
So we have to do a bunch of
hacks to actually produce
quality and it doesn't
behave like H.264
would in that situation.
So how will VP9 address that
problem, or is that even on
the roadmap?
RONALD BULTJE: So in general,
desktop sharing and
applications like this, also
real time communications, yes,
they're on the roadmap,
and yes,
they will all be supported.
In terms of your specific
problem, I guess the best
thing to do is why don't you
come and see us afterwards in
the Chrome [INAUDIBLE], and we
can actually look at that.
AUDIENCE: OK, awesome.
RONALD BULTJE: As for VP9,
VP9 currently does not
have a one pass mode.
We've removed that to just speed
up development, but it
will eventually be re-added, and
it will be as fast as the
VP8 one but with a 50% reduction
in bit rate.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
a timeline for that?
Is it going to this year,
or next year?
RONALD BULTJE: Like Matt said,
that will happen--
MATT FROST: Late Q3.
RONALD BULTJE: Q3 2013,
around then.
We're currently focusing on
YouTube, and those kind of
things will come after that.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have two questions,
unrelated
questions to that.
What is the latency performance
of VP8 compared to
VP9 in terms of decoding
and encoding?
And the second question is, how
does VP9 compare to H.265?
RONALD BULTJE: So I think H.265,
I addressed earlier.
So do you want me to go into
that further, or was that OK?
AUDIENCE: More in terms of the
real time performance.
RONALD BULTJE: So in terms of
real time performance, I think
for both, that's really, really
hard to say because
there is no real time HEVC
encoder and there is no real
time VP9 encoder.
So I can sort of guess, but
this is something that the
future will have to tell us.
We will put a lot of effort
into writing real time
encoders or adapting our
encoder to be real time
capable because that is
very important for us.
MATT FROST: But in terms of
raw latency, it should be
faster than VP8.
You can decode the first
frame, right?
RONALD BULTJE: I think it
will be the same as VP8.
So VP8 allows one frame in, one
frame out, and VP9 will
allow exactly that same
frame control model.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned that
you've asked hardware
manufacturers for any concerns
or comments.
Have you gotten any yet?
MATT FROST: Sorry.
Are considering supporting it?
AUDIENCE: Well, in terms of
the algorithms and how you
would actually--
MATT FROST: They're working
on it quickly.
AUDIENCE: But there's no
concerns or comments or
anything yet?
MATT FROST: No concerns.
AUDIENCE: You said you opened
up for comments.
MATT FROST: No.
We have received comments.
We have a hardware team
internally that took a first
pass at comments.
We've received a couple of
comments additionally just
saying, here's some stuff you're
doing in software that
doesn't implement well,
and hardware.
I don't foresee a lot of
additional comments from the
hardware manufacturers.
The other work that we're doing
over the next 45 days is
we had a bunch of experiments
that we had to close out, and
so we're doing some closing
out as well and just
finishing the code.
Absent act of God, this is bit
stream final on June 17.
RONALD BULTJE: So we have
actually received comments
from some hardware
manufacturers, and we are
actively addressing the ones
that we're getting.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I might have missed this, but
when did you say the ARM
optimizations for VP9 are
going to come out?
MATT FROST: Actually starting
now really, we're focusing on
doing some optimizations by
ourselves and with partners.
So I would say that's going to
be coming out second half of
the year, and it'll probably be
sort of incremental where
you may get an initial pass of
ARM optimizations and then
some final optimization.
It's obviously very important
for us for Android to be able
to get VP9 working as well as
possible, and obviously, ARM
is incredibly important for
the Android ecosystem, so
that's an area of significant
focus.
AUDIENCE: And in terms of real
time encoding, so in order to
blend into WebRTC,
you're going to
have to get that working.
So is this going to coincide
with the assimilation of VP9
into WebRTC?
MATT FROST: It'll be real time
optimizations, which I think
we were sort of thinking about
end of Q3, beginning of Q4,
and then integration into WebRTC
will follow on that.
Obviously, the one thing
I'd say, it's
an open source project.
If you guys think that you see
an opportunity, you can go out
and do the optimizations
yourselves.
There are contractors
who can do it.
So I encourage you guys to think
about that, that you can
take the code and you can start
working on some of this
stuff yourselves.
Obviously, we'd love it if you'd
contribute it back but
we're not going to
force you to.
Yeah, I guess last question.
AUDIENCE: This is a question
about how VP9 relates to what
the Android team talked about
with Google proxy and the
speedy proxy.
You alluded to transcoding
real time for backwards
compatible device support.
Do you see Google doing the same
thing they're going to do
with images in this proxy and
doing video transcoding to
adapt this and use this
for compression mode
in the Google proxy?
RONALD BULTJE: That's a really
interesting application, and
that's something that we'll have
to look into the future.
It's not as easy as it sounds
because video transcoding
actually takes some time.
So that would mean that you
would actually have to wait a
minute while the video is
transcoding until you can
visit that website, and that
might not be quite what you're
looking for.
But it's an interesting
application and we might look
into that in the future.
MATT FROST: I think that's it.
I think we're out of time.
Sorry, but we're happy to
talk to you afterwards.
[APPLAUSE]